hey youtubers is Charlie so Zack Snyder
released the first official pic of Jason
Momoa as Aquaman last night and the
picture says unite the seven what does
that mean mostly the original 7 members
of the Justice League there's a bit of a
twist to that because in the original
Justice League the lineup was Superman
Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman flash Green
Lantern and Martian Manhunter but notice
that of all the solo films that Warner
Brothers has lined up there is no
Martian Manhunter solo film so he is
probably not going to appear in Batman
for superman donna justice so slight
tweak to the Justice League lineup it
looks a little bit more like the lineup
of the modern Justice League they're
just trading cyborg for Martian
Manhunter why would they do that you ask
changed so much about what people love
about the original Justice League I'd
say mostly because that was in 1960 and
more people are familiar with the cyborg
character now than are with a Martian
Manhunter character yes Martian
Manhunter has appeared in a lot of the
animated movies and he appeared on the
Smallville live-action television series
but I think largely due to the
popularity of the teen titans comics as
well as all the teen titans shows most
of the people that Warner Brothers
expects to go see this film mainly young
males are more familiar with the cyborg
character and they feel like they can
market a cyborg
solo film better than they can market a
solo Martian Manhunter film you have to
imagine that the characters that they
put in there Justice League have to be
able to lead their own solo titles and
in order to make a successful solo film
they have to get people who have never
read a comic book and have no idea who
the cyborg character is to go out and
see a cyborg movie that's the challenge
that Warner Brothers has right now I
mean people who have never read a
Justice Lee comic probably have a vague
idea who's cyborg is but in order for a
movie to make like 500 600 700 million
dollars they have to get people that
don't go to superhero movies to go to a
superhero movie and in order for that to
happen they have to get people to
connect with the character and they feel
like it's easier to get people to
connect with an african-american
football star who gets turned into a
monster than to get them to connect with
a green person from Mars that you know
the origin story of cyborg just easier
to connect with through your average
viewer than it is for the origin story
of Martian Manhunter that's just my
opinion but but on
it just feels like they think it's
easier to do cyber work than it is to do
martian manhunter here's an interesting
thought - do you think that that's why
we're seeing more cyborgs in the comics
than Martian Manhunter like they just
they want people by the time we get to
this cyborg solo film to be more aware
of his character so they're just they're
downplaying Martian Manhunter Marvel
Comics is kind of doing that thing where
they're they're slowly moving the comics
to be more congruous with what's going
on in the films although the comics will
always be their own thing you have to
remember that no matter how well comics
sell they make a fraction like a small
fraction of the money that Warner
Brothers and Disney Marvel make on their
films TV everything else so that that's
why you shouldn't worry too much about
what's going on in the comics having any
bearing about what's going on in films
or the TV shows and that's across the
board that's Marvel and Warner Brothers
if you haven't read it the original
Justice League makeup was actually
pretty interesting they debuted in the
Brave and the bold number 28 in 1960
they fought star oh they haven't
confirmed which big villains Superman
Batman Wonder Woman are gonna be
fighting in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice but the rumor is the Lex Luthor
will be involved in the creation of a
doomsday like character whether or not
it's like the doomsday in the comics I
have no idea the weird thing about the
movies right now is that kryptonite does
not exist when Zack Snyder made the
first man to steal movie he's like no
there is no such thing as kryptonite the
rumors is that eventually synthetic
kryptonite will exist like Lex Luthor
will find a way to synthesize kryptonite
because of what happened with the
Kryptonian terraformers in the first Man
of Steel film they were slowly
converting the earth into something that
was just like Krypton and because like
each of these new films like these
Justice League character films will flow
from each other the creation of
kryptonite will flow from the logic of
what happened during Man of Steel you
have to remember that this is a
superhero film so sprinkle some movie
logic on top of that really when you
think about it Jason Momoa is probably
one of the perfect people to be Aquaman
he's from Hawaii and don't you think
that Aquaman would be from some sort of
Pacific island nation regardless of
where it was in the world as you can see
from the picture they do try to honor
his scaled costume but the style just
fits with the tone that Zack Snyder's
going for but he really Tunes his colors
down it's much more like the 300 version
of what Aquaman would look like as
opposed to like that cartoon version
with the orange costume because we're
meeting him for the first
time in Batman vs Superman we'll
probably get something of an origin
story maybe some flashbacks and then the
solo film the solo aquaman film will
deal with the rest of that here's an
interesting question why are they
introducing Aquaman first and why does
it say unite the seven probably because
Aquaman is gonna be the one to bring
them together that's an interesting
thought because Wonder Woman is the
diplomat so you think that she'd be the
one to bring them together but she's
more of a warrior
Batman's more of a loner and Superman
he's a broody alien that tries to take
all of the world's problems on himself
the difference between them and Aquaman
is that 70% of the earth is water and he
is king of all of that so technically he
is the king of the earth when you think
about it that way the earth is one
organism there are no nations no
boundary lines it's all one big group of
people and organisms working together so
so logically Aquaman would be the one to
say hey we are all the same we need to
work together I mean it's not gonna be
as simple as that but yeah Aquaman king
of 70% of the earth much bigger than the
other 30% that the other superheroes
live on add to that that Aquaman is one
of the few characters that's just as
powerful as Superman or Wonder Woman
Zack Snyder whenever he was defending
the idea of Aquaman to this weird radio
station he was talking about how
Aquaman's Trident can pierce Superman's
skin so it's like they have some sort of
equal footing it'll be interesting to
see because there's no such thing as
kryptonite right now so technically
under under most circumstances
Superman is invincible Batman vs
Superman is gonna change that like we'll
probably see some kryptonite
we'll see a villain the Superman can't
beat by himself which is why they have
to start working together then obviously
that's going to lead into the Justice
League film and then all those solo
films so think of Batman vs Superman is
like a soft intro to Justice League so
everything in this story leads to that
everything has the goal of uniting the
seven but I'm really interested to see
is if they go with the idea of the
watchtower and outer space or if they
have something that's a little more
practical on earth the watchtower didn't
come so much later in the comics
originally they all lived on earth so I
think that's what'll end up happening
for those that are really upset that
Martian Manhunter has has no part in
these films as far as we know right now
I think eventually they'll get there I
think I think they're just like a little
bit behind Marvel in terms of rolling
out the more fantastical things but they
haven't gotten to magic yet they do have
their black atom so eventually we'll get
there
so here's my big question for you guys
what do you think about Jason Momoa 'z
look and what do you think about the
idea of the Seven original Justice
League members teaming up by the end of
the film I feel like they've cast a
bunch of great actors like they have a
bunch of characters that can carry solo
films but I'll be really interested to
see what it all looks like when they get
on film because most of it is gonna
focus on Batman and Superman there's no
way that they can give each character
equal screen time so a lot of these
other Justice League people will be
background players until they get to
their solo films and until we get to
Justice League here's something funny to
think about too if you feel like 7
Justice League characters is a lot of
characters to have in a movie there's
gonna be like 9 to 10 members of the
Avengers in age of Ultron depending on
whether or not you count war machine as
a member of the Avengers so it can
totally be done they can totally have a
bunch of characters in a film and it
could still work and if you want more
proof than that Bryan Singer's original
x-men films were amazing he made great
ensemble films it just it's a very
different skill for a director to have
to be able to work with that many big
characters on screen at once and for
those that are upset about the TV
characters like Stephen Amell Grant
Gustin not being the film's don't don't
worry by the time those films come out
they'll be so incredibly popular Stephen
Amell Grant Gustin that it won't even
matter like they won't even care the
flash is like the most popular TV show
that DC has had in forever and it's only
in season 1 so he is totally not bitter
about any of that stuff so I'm still
gonna be doing my arrow flash Q&A I'll
be sure to answer questions about
Justice League stuff in that too so feel
free to ask be sure to subscribe to get
it I'll post it later today I'll be
posting like tonight so while you guys
wait for that to drop you can click here
to catch up on the flash and you can
click here to catch up on arrow this
week thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you